[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEITH DANEKIND: Welcome to
the Apigee Up Close webcast.
We do these twice a month.
The topics are based
on popular demand.
You can sign up multiple times.
And you can ask questions live.
Hi, I'm Keith Danekind.
And I'm a customer
engineer with Apigee,
part of Google Cloud platform.
Today we're going
to be the top 10
tips to help you have a better
API program in the new year.
So if you're wanting to put
together a checklist of things
you should do to make sure
you have a successful API
program in 2019, what
will be on your list?
I've been talking
with my colleagues
at Apigee about
their suggestions.
And I put together a list
of the top 10 suggestions.
They fell roughly under
three categories--
process tips, product tips, and
infrastructure and DevOps tips.
So let's get started.
I'm going to start
with four topics
on improving your process.
So number one, think outside in.
If you've attended an
Apigee webcast before,
you've probably seen this.
It's core to how we think about
how API management should work.
It's worth taking another look
in the context of this webcast.
We've seen a repeated pattern
of success with our customers,
and it's driven by how they
think about the API problem.
It requires a shift in thinking.
Traditionally, we
think about services
from an exposure point of view.
We can just expose the
service and be finished.
But thinking about it from
the end user's point of view
leads to better results.
Our successful customers
start with the user,
thinking about what that
user's experience will be like
and working
backwards from there.
Providing application
developers with great APIs
reduces the complexity of
creating new applications.
The developer's free to
focus on user experience
and iterate on a few
different designs.
The API team makes this
possible by providing
an easy to use API with
consistent interfaces
and security.
The API team builds
the API facades
on the existing services,
abstracting away
the complexity.
This makes it easy to
build great APIs that
are easy to use.
So keep this pattern in mind
when you build your APIs.
Tip number two, develop
an API product mindset.
So APIs are not
one-off products,
but products that need
continuous iteration
and development.
So focus on that lifecycle.
So what does it mean
to productize an API?
There's many aspects
we might talk about,
but we find it helpful to
focus on these three items--
outside in, speed to market,
and iterative delivery.
It might help to
look at an example.
Let's look at how Walgreens
talks about their API products.
They've got a bunch of
different API products.
And they're split into all
these different categories
that you see on the slide here.
This is very deliberate in
terms of how they package these
and how they manage them
and things like that.
So Walgreens says that
their API products
are managed like
any other product
within their digital
product portfolio.
There are a few keys to success
for what that looks like.
They have a product
roadmap for APIs
and present it quarterly to
their entire digital product
team-- partners, business
teams, marketing,
and other key stakeholders.
So there is great visibility
into what they're doing.
And it's a great source of
opportunity and partnership
with other teams.
Second thing, they have a
fantastic developer evangelist.
And he actually sits
within the product team.
So the partnership with
the product managers
is very strong.
Next, they have great tools
to engage with their developer
community and manage
their API program.
They have a developer portal,
which is the initial entry
point to their APIs.
And of course, they
have Apigee, which
allows them to be a great
partner to their developer
community.
And last but definitely
not least, they
put a big focus, as
with any other product,
on defining what
success looks like
and reporting out
their performance
against those metrics.
So another tip is to create
an API product manager role.
That's somebody who's
going to manage APIs
across the entire lifecycle.
They're going to take that
vision and turn it into action.
And they're a subject
matter expert.
So tip number three, focus
on the application developer.
So why are API
developers so important?
API consumer adoption is key
to success for any API program.
APIs will need to be
marketed to API consumers
as products, not
just as raw services.
Application developers are
your ultimate consumers,
so keep them in mind when you're
developing your API program.
You may have different types
of application developers
who have different
requirements for your APIs.
For example, you might
have internal application
developers, partners
application developers,
and external application
developers all building
different things,
all with different
wants and needs when it
comes to your API program.
Shutterstock is creating a
great developer experience
by answering the most
important questions that
arise during
development and creating
a great "getting started"
and onboarding experience.
So imagine that you're
an API consumer.
You're an application developer,
and you go to their website.
This is great.
It's got everything you
need to get started,
and they reduce the
amount of friction,
encouraging people
to develop things.
So tip number
four, pick an MVBO.
Where do you start
with your API project?
Using an MVBO is a
great place to start.
So what is an MBVO?
An MVBO is a Minimum
Viable Business Outcome.
It's a small yet
business-critical delivery
that showcases the opportunity
and starts building
ongoing delivery momentum.
So how do you pick a good MVBO?
The MVBO should focus
on creating milestones
for business enablement and
pave the path for others
to follow it.
And the MVBO should be
ready, it should be engaging,
and it should be
sufficiently difficult.
Let's look at each of
those in a bit more detail.
So ready means that
the project you pick
can get into production
quickly and demonstrate value.
Speed is going to
be essential here.
So that means you should avoid
complex program or delivery
dependencies, avoid target
backend systems that
require significant refactoring,
avoid use cases where
the user base or customer
demand does not already exist.
It should be engaging, so make
sure your project is engaging.
You need to deliver something
of clear business value
and impact aligned to strategic
goals and sponsor interest.
It should deliver strategic
value, deliver business value.
It should resonate
with your audience,
and it should create a pathway
for repeatable success.
Your MVBO should be
sufficiently difficult.
The APIs delivered should
not just be pass-throughs.
They should be complex enough to
demonstrate key API management
benefits, including controlled
access to resources and assets,
analytics, self-service
consumption via a developer
portal, and they should
demonstrate how they'll scale.
So consider all
those things when
you're thinking about an MVBO.
Next, let's look at three
tips in the product category.
Number five, standardize
the security.
Backend services often
have different protocols
for authentication depending
on when they were developed.
Navigating those multiple
security protocols
causes extra work
for API consumers.
Consider standardizing
the security you
present to your API consumers.
They'll be much happier and
they'll thank you for this.
An API platform can help you
standardize your security.
In addition to policies
for authentication,
there's policies for
rate limiting and quotas,
payload protection, and more.
Your API platform
can control access
to protected resources to
help you with compliance also.
You may need to tie into an
existing identity management
system.
This is an example
of a flow that
generates an OAuth token after
users enter their passwords.
The authentication flow makes a
call out to the identity system
to verify the user's
username and password.
And if the credentials
are accepted,
it returns a token to the
application that is then
sent to the business flow.
So simple example
of how you might
integrate with an existing
identity management system.
Number six, measure,
monitor, and improve.
So how do you improve
your API program?
Measuring how
applications call it
and monitoring the
performance will
help you know what
needs to be tuned
and give you data on how
your program is doing.
So after you've built a few APIs
and your application developers
have discovered them and
started to send you traffic,
it'd great if you could
measure your API program.
The analytics system
in [INAUDIBLE]
allows you to measure every
aspect of your API traffic.
You can measure
operational details
like response time, frequency
of different types of errors.
You can find things that are
interesting to your business,
like where are people located
when they call your APIs,
or which applications are
sending the most traffic?
Maybe it's interesting to
see what type of client
they're using.
Are they on Internet Explorer?
Are they on Chrome?
Are they on different
mobile platforms?
All of these things
can be answered
with analytics reports.
So what should you be measuring?
Here's a list of some
of the common metrics
that we've heard from customers
that they find valuable.
So think about the number of
APIs, the number of developers,
the number of customers,
the number of partners,
the number of apps, the speed
to API, speed to onboard--
so in other words, how long does
it take to get up and going?--
traffic growth, business breath,
cost reduction, direct revenue,
and net promoter score.
Apigee has some great reports
to help you understand your API
program.
For example, here is
an engagement report
that shows you how
many developers
are using your platform and
their level of engagement.
So one final important aspect
of operating an API Platform
is ensuring the
availability of your APIs.
Apigee launched API monitoring
product a couple of weeks ago,
freely available now to all
cloud-based enterprise edge
customers.
So please check that out.
So number seven, get the
right value from your APIs.
The value generated by
APIs does not typically
come from charging
for API calls.
Most of the value comes from
business opportunities enabled
by the APIs and the
applications that use them.
Make sure your
APIs deliver value,
either directly or indirectly.
Consider measuring your rate of
innovation or your time to app.
While an API may not
directly generate revenue,
what value does it bring if
you can create applications
in a month instead of a year?
Can APIs provide you with
new sources of value?
Do you have unique data that
might be valuable to others?
Can you charge for it?
What new channels of
business can you explore?
Accuweather is able to monetize
their data by packaging it
into different offerings
with different price points.
So think of approaches for
how you might want to do this.
Next, let's shift to
infrastructure and DevOps.
I have four tips
in this category.
Tip number eight,
automate and integrate.
The UI is great, but
automation is even better.
Most users start
off with the UI,
but they'll move to automating
parts of their processes.
Apigee has a great
set of management APIs
that allow you to automate
every aspect of the platform.
Take a look at the reference
docs and start exploring these.
I've got the URL
on the screen here.
The Apigee community
is a great place
to find advice and resources
for SICD automation.
There's a lot of people who've
gone through this before you.
And there's links to tools and
discussion of how to use them.
Number nine, grow
with microservices.
Microservices enable developers
to build and deploy software
with speed, agility, and
scale necessary to meet
the needs of your business.
You can decompose a
monolithic application
into a set of services that
can be developed and released
independently.
Microservices are an
architecture approach
to software development
where software
is composed of small independent
services that communicate over
well-defined APIs.
Microservices enable
modern enterprises
to create a flexible
architecture,
where services can be
versioned, deployed,
and scaled without impact to the
other systems or applications.
So the great thing
about microservices
is that they can easily
grow with your business.
But that comes with
some new complexities.
An app development team may
rush to implement microservices.
And when they do this,
they inadvertently
create silos with
inconsistencies
in security, visibility,
documentation, and governance.
Many of the APIs that
connect microservices
are not secured consistently
across the organization.
So these microservices
and associate APIs
are often difficult
to reuse, analyze,
or even to discover
for use by their teams.
You can solve this
problem by managing
the consumption of
your microservices
with your API platform.
So number 10, let's talk
about cloud migration.
Migrating to the cloud
isn't a straight path.
Enterprises adopt
different paths
to define their cloud strategy.
Often, enterprises will
pick multiple paths
based on different
projects or workloads.
So there's three key
takeaways from the slide.
Migration paths will vary,
even within a company
and across applications.
Migrations are not instant.
Some take months or even years.
Across all the
paths of migration,
API management can
play a key role
in making integrations easier.
So how can API management help?
So few different
things to look at here.
Apigee can help with many of
these different challenges.
Service connectivity.
One of the primary
concerns of app migration
is tight coupling of the
clients or user experiences
to the backend services or apps.
Apigee acts as an abstraction
layer between the exposure
and consumption, allowing
for service connectivity
while parts of the app's
backend or front end
are migrated to the cloud.
Security enforcement.
Apigee can act both as
a security enforcement
layer as well as a
security mediation layer.
As apps are modernized
while moving to the cloud,
it's very common
for the modern apps
to have a different security
mechanism, like JWT or OAth,
versus the legacy
traditional backends,
like SAML, BasicAuth, et cetera.
Apigee can bring in uniformity
by allowing the modern apps
to use one common
mechanism while mediating
the credentials while talking
to the legacy backends, and vice
versa.
Apigee can also make sure that
security mechanisms like regex
checks, DLP enforcement are
done while on-prem apps that
have strict compliance needs
are calling the cloud workloads.
For visibility.
By acting as the facade
across on-prem GCP workloads,
Apigee can provide visibility
into how app migrations are
happening and the success or
traction for the migrated apps.
The API metrics
that Apigee provides
are slightly higher
level, as Apigee
will have visibility into which
apps developer clients are
calling your API, which
API product is being used
to call the API, and et cetera.
The API metrics can be pulled in
through Apigee's management API
and analyzed along with other
operational metrics collected
by the apps logging
framework, et cetera.
API facades.
So most often, not
all of the apps
can be migrated once the
re-platform to modernized apps
will have to talk to
a monolith or a legacy
or traditional backend.
These backends most of the
time will be legacy protocols
like SOAP, XML.
It's not ideal for modern
apps to consume them that way.
And it adds the
additional burden
of maintaining
additional libraries,
making the app
heavier and complex.
Apigee can help
create API facades
that are modern while
keeping the monolith intact.
The re-platformed or modern
apps can talk to these facades
instead of going
directly to the backend.
And finally, service management.
Lift and modernization is
one of the standard themes
of app migration.
Microservices,
offered on Kubernetes,
is a vehicle for
app modernization.
As enterprises
realize the success
of microservices-based
architectures,
the number of
microservices explodes,
and the apps are
migrated to cloud
without the right
security and visibility.
It's extremely
difficult to accelerate
the adoption of microservices.
Some enterprises are
already looking at Istio
to solve this problem.
For customers who
have adopted Istio,
Apigee can provide enterprise
support for non-GCP Istio
implementations as well as add
the higher level API management
aspects like OAuth
through the mixer adapter.
For customers who are
not looking at Istio,
example, customers
who are on PCF--
Apigee's micro gateway can
add similar capabilities
and manage their microservices,
like security and analytics.
So that's the top 10 list.
Next up, let's take
some questions.
OK.
Let's start off with
the first question.
Where should I start
with the management APIs?
How can they be used to
automate my deployment?
So take a look at the
reference section of the API
documentation for Apigee.
And in there you'll see
a list of all those.
Pick one or two and play
with it and just get
a feel for how it works.
One thing people
will commonly do
is automate the deployment
process, meaning,
if you're going to push
something, for example from dev
to test or from, maybe,
test or QA into production,
you can automate that.
So take a look at
the management API,
specifically around that
area and give that a try.
Next question has to deal
with analytics and measuring
your APIs.
And the question in
there is, how can I
measure something business
specific with a custom report
in Apigee?
So there's a statistics
collector policy in there.
The statistics
collector policy lets
you grab anything that's
a variable in Apigee,
so anything from the
request the response
or anything you want to
extract out of there.
You can save that
as a custom metric.
And that can be used in
the reporting system.
So you can combine that
with the built in analytics,
build a custom
report, and measure
something that's interesting.
So think about what you might--
what you might want
to measure with that.
Next question.
You touched on experience API.
What is an experience API?
So think of an experience
as an application,
or how somebody would
experience your services.
So a lot of times we'll
build custom services just
for a particular application.
You might have an
experience API to support
a mobile application.
And what's nice about having
an API platform for this
is it lets you
easily build a custom
API that's specific
to the experience
that you're trying to share.
So next one in
here is a question
about getting started
with using APIs
for consuming microservices.
So what are the best practices?
And how do you get
started with this?
So I'm going to go back to that
outside-in type of thinking.
So think about how we want to
control how people experience
these microservices.
A great place to put
Apigee is right on top
of those microservices.
And it would be used to control
access for external consumers.
So put Apigee in there
and treat the backend
like you would any
other backend, only
it's going to be
microservices in this case.
So what about measuring the
number of active subscriptions?
That's a great idea.
So that is a good
metric to measure.
So you could do that through
some of the built-in reports
that are in Apigee.
Particularly, there's
a developer engagement
one that will show
you who's subscribed
and what they're doing
and things like that.
There's a question in here
where the listener missed
some bits of authentication.
What's the best way to integrate
with vendors like Octa,
SSO for OAuth, or
Abstract from end users?
So there's a great
webcast out there
that you may have
seen last year.
Take a look out on the
YouTube channel for Apigee.
I've got another
webcast out there that
just deals with that topic.
So basically, there are
policies inside of Apigee
that will generate OAuth tokens.
And what you'll do is, the
generation of that token--
if you just put
that in your flow,
it's just going to
generate a token.
Typically, what
people will do is
they're going to put
some logic in front
of that to generate-- or
not to generate, to call out
to the identity
management system
and verify the user in some way.
And then if and only
if they're good will
they generate the token.
So that's the general
pattern in there.
But there's a whole
webcast on that.
Take a look on the
YouTube channel.
And you'll see under the
Apigee Up Close series,
there is a webcast just
covering that topic.
There's a question in here.
Transitioning to
the API world is
disruptive to existing
internal dev community.
What tips can you give
for elevating internal dev
community learning, how best
to promote and encourage?
So I would explore, why is it
disruptive to move to the API
world?
And what is it about that?
Some of the things
we'd focus on is,
what's the onboarding
process for APIs?
So is it easier if you have
an API management platform
in place?
Is there a developer portal
where they can go and find
examples and things like that.
So it should be something the
developers are excited about.
And it should be something
that can be done in a way
that it's not too disruptive.
So explore where the friction
is in there and work on that.
So what best describes
the attributes
of an API or a digital team?
So we'll rephrase this
as, who's on that team
or what they're doing.
So when you're first
getting started,
this might be a smaller team.
There might be
people on there who
are going to be building APIs.
And those might be people who
built web services in the past,
or at least they have a
knowledge of what the back end
services are and
can look at those
and figure out what to expose.
Over time we'd like to add an
API product manager because we
want to think about
these things as products,
manage their lifecycle,
and things like that.
So that's going to be
somebody who's a little bit
more business focused.
You may have some
people on there
who are viewing reports
and measuring things.
They'd probably fall into that
product manager role, also.
You may have some
people in there
who are going to be
consuming these APIs.
But the team varies quite a bit.
You'll find a lot of different
people on the API team.
There's a question here.
For enterprises
with B2B partners,
can Apigee play an outbound
API call management
role, management of calls
originating from inside?
So yeah, we do see this.
So the pattern here
is that you can
manage any kind of API call.
So maybe you're calling
out or maybe you're
receiving calls coming in.
Either way, you can think
of this as a good place
to have API
management, if you want
to be able to measure
that traffic, if you want
to be able to control it,
reshape requests, and things
like that.
You can use it for inside
calls or for outside calls
and whether you're
calling in or out.
Question here is, is
there such a thing
as a private, internal API?
If yes, how is it
treated differently?
So private or internal API--
I might think of that
as an experience API.
And really, the only thing
that's going to make it private
versus public is how
you choose to expose it
and who has access to
it and who can use it.
But we see this commonly.
We'll see people have
completely big internal API
programs at their
companies, where they're
developing all these things
and none of it's exposed
externally.
So that's a very
common use case.
Next question-- can Apigee
support custom transformations?
Also, does Apigee support
API orchestration?
So for custom transformations,
yes, very much so.
So we have built in
transformations in there
for JSON to XML, XML to JSON.
You can also use XXLT in there
if you're working with XML.
And there's support for
using different languages
in there for custom policy.
So Java, JavaScript,
and Python can be used.
And they have complete
control over the request
and the response flow.
So one thing that's
very common is
you might write a
little bit of JavaScript
or Java code in there.
And that would transform the
response that comes back.
That's a common use case.
On the second side
of that, can Apigee
support API orchestration?
Yes, that's a common use case.
So you're going to
have one call in,
and then you might call two
or three different services
on the backend, collect
those responses,
and orchestrate them.
So yeah, you could do that.
There's direct call
outs to do that if you
want to do it synchronously.
If you want to do
it asynchronously,
you can do it with some of the
built-in programming languages
for the custom policies.
The question here is a
response to the other one.
Thank you for clarifying
on experience APIs.
How does it work
with API facades?
Do they complement or
supplement each other?
So an experience API
is really something
that's custom built to support
a particular application.
A facade I would describe
as, what you're doing
is you're hiding away the
complexities of the enterprise.
So you're separating
the external interface
from the internal
implementation of that API.
So think about, how
would you ideally like
to have this API look
to the outside world?
And build an interface
that looks like that.
And then map that to
the internal services.
And that can be done in a
number of different ways.
But really, the difference
between these two
is the intention.
Are we building this
for a specific use?
Or is this just
a general purpose
way to improve and simplify
how our API is to call?
How do you demonstrate the
value of API-driven architecture
within an enterprise
if they're happy
with an ESB-led architecture?
Yeah, that's a tough one.
So I would say, once they get
to see something like this,
they would absolutely love it.
If I'm thinking old school
ESB-style architecture, where
this would be better
is, think about,
how long does it take you
to develop an application?
So if you wanted to write a
[INAUDIBLE] single page web
application or a new
mobile application,
what's that process like,
and how long does it
take to do something like that?
Also, where's the documentation?
Is there a developer
portal today
that has everything
somebody would be on there?
What's the process for
a developer to onboard?
So those are a
few things to look
at that might help with that.
Can you map existing
microservices to Apigee?
How can you achieve that?
So yeah, you sure can.
So think about it like
the backend is going
to be a set of microservices.
So you're going to build
a facade on top of that,
build a proxy in Apigee.
And that will talk to those
various backend systems.
OK.
A few more questions coming in.
What's my opinion
on API versioning,
putting the version at the
level the path or the content?
So this is one of those
things that's very
contentious in the API world.
How do you do versioning?
I've seen many different
ways to do this.
The most common I have
seen, and the advice
that we tend to give, is
put the version in the URL,
and keep it as far to
the left as possible.
So that's the most
common we see.
I've seen it done
in headers, though.
I've seen it done in a
number of different ways.
But that's the most
common that I'm seeing.
Does Apigee Istio replace
existing middleware integration
and adapter technologies?
Istio would help you manage
a set of microservices.
Sometimes those microservice
might be replacing
internal technologies.
Sometimes they might
be supplementing them.
I'm seeing a lot of folks do
microservices for new projects.
And they would be complementary
or supplemental to existing
things that are in place.
OK.
I'm going to take a
few more questions,
and then we'll
move on to a whole.
Thank you for all the questions.
I've got a lot of them in here.
There's a question in here.
Is there a way to onboard
an API developer manually?
Currently, the
developer subscription
is done automatically.
I have a use case
where I want to do
some verification before
granting the subscription.
Is this possible?
So yes, it is.
You can check in Apigee--
you can set up that it's
going to be done manually.
And then you can go
into the dashboard
where you approve apps.
And you would have to
approve it in there.
It can also be done
through an API.
OK.
I'll take two more,
and then we'll wrap up.
Can Apigee leverage
cloud functions
or use a cloud function
as the backend API source?
Can it use Pubsub for queuing?
So yes, absolutely.
So a few different
ways to do this.
We've got some connectors that
are in Apigee for Google cloud
platform.
So if you're working on
Google cloud platform,
you'll find built
in support for this.
If you happen to be working
on AWS or another cloud,
check our
documentation for that.
There are some examples
of doing lambda functions.
Or in other cases,
as long as something
has an API that can be
connected to through HTTP,
this is going to be
pretty easy to do.
What's the preferred approach
to restrict access to APIs
protected by Apigee so traffic
must go through Apigee first?
Firewall rules,
TLS certificates--
how do we do that?
So yes, firewall rules
and TLS certificates
would be two ways to do that.
But basically, some form
of cutting off access that
doesn't go through Apigee.
And that's typically done
through networking techniques.
All right.
Our next webcast
coming up on January 17
is hybrid apps, migration,
and modernization and the need
for API management.
Thank you for attending today.
And happy new year
to everyone out there
from everyone at Apigee.